i started my organization exactly for
what you were talking about that these
these urban elites these people who were
three generations removed from
oh maybe my grandfather was a coal miner
or my great-grandfather but now i am a
true
urbanite and i'm an urbanite i grew up
in new york city etc etc
but they make decisions about the
livelihood of people
in towns michael bloomberg is going out
of his way to close coal mines in
america
he he is destroying small towns in
kentucky west virginia
new mexico wyoming he wouldn't land one
of his
g6s in west virginia because there's no
four seasons there
he wouldn't spend a second in artesia
new mexico
but he will destroy their livelihood he
will take away the only source of income
they have
and that is shameful bloomberg is the
guy who said to tax the poor
because they're too stupid to spend
their own money properly and in that
same speech which was with christine
lagarde at some
uh you know you know um bilderberg
conference
he said you know the coal miners we'll
find other things for them to do
code and i thought we will find other
things for them to do first of all who
the heck is we
and what are these other things do they
get a choice it's like john kerry
talking about well they have a better
choice
now they'll become solar panel
technicians do i get to say
this new job right what am i what did
you did you see what uh
what cast am i born into who was it was
it was it peter ducey or steve
i don't know which one's the kid which
one's the dad the fox news journalist he
asked jen sackey
the biden administration press secretary
a lot of uh people just lost jobs
because joe biden ended the keystone
pipeline construction it was like 10 000
good union jobs gone when can they
expect to get these green jobs that
biden has
promised and her response was can you
prove to me they can't get jobs
and he was like what you no no but biden
said there will be new green jobs i'm
asking when like
i don't know what you're talking or like
it was it was entirely adversarial
the idea that the problem with this
though is you think somebody who knows
how to build an oil pipeline that line
of work can just magically teleport to a
solar plant
a solar power a solar panel factory and
no know what they're doing we've already
said though that solar panels isn't the
answer we need new battery tech
right and when you ask these politicians
how what are you going to do they're
like
i will find the best minds that will
figure out how to do it
but another thing we really need to
discuss that that's not really talked
about a lot especially in american
mainstream media
is the waste is the pollution is the
utter crap that's being spewed by
third world countries countries like
china that pollute on massive levels and
there's
there's no regulations there's no
michael bloomberg flying over there
telling them what to do no 95 of the
plastics in the ocean
come from southeast asia 70 percent of
it comes specifically from
hold on hold on greta toonberg says
we're the ones who got to change and
she doesn't go to china what do we do we
ban straws
just think about the logic of this right
there is so much plastic in the pacific
ocean
that washington dc has a strawband and
you say well
what the heck does one have to do with
the other well it feels good and why we
applaud this
yeah i was in i was in texas i was doing
i think i i think was when i won the
glenn beck program and i was at a uh
some restaurant in the airport i ordered
an arnold palmer
uh i enjoyed arnold palmer you guys like
lovely drink well the waitress came up
to me and she was uh it was it was kind
of funny because she handed me a paper
straw
and she apologized and i laughed she no
no no she legit she like
brought to me and she pulled the paper
straws i'm sorry yeah and i looked at i
started laughing and i was like i
it's fine and she goes why did they ban
straws
and then she brought up your point i'm
like here's a waitress who knows that we
are not
and then i asked her about it i was like
that's a really good point and most
people don't know that
and started talking to me about a bunch
of political stuff and i'm like
how is it this waitress knows and
understands the problem better than
these politicians do i know
that's the problem a regular person
looks into it researches and says
well what is banning straws going to do
do you ever see the video of the straw
up the turtle's nose
and these people find this turtle
swimming in the water and they pull it
out and it's stuck
so they take pliers and they go and they
start to try and pull it out of the
turtle and it starts bleeding and the
turtle's screaming in pain
it's a video on youtube i'm sure and um
they they just work his face and
basically commit surgery on this
distress so plastic in the ocean is
devastating
no one's denying that but but but it's
not we're not the ones who
are doing it but why is greta tunberg
coming and speaking to europeans and
americans saying how dare you we must
stop it's like okay can we fly to china
so you can have a conversation with what
they're doing
like i'm not trying to i mean literally
china right now
as we are speaking is building more coal
plants
than all of europe currently has
actually and they promised to stop
there they lied absolutely and they're
never going to stop
why are they building coal plants
because it works you can say coal is bad
you can say coal is good
i am going to say coal works and china
is serious
they have a world to conquer they're not
going to face what texas is facing you
think china's going to allow
one of this uyghur concentration camps
making nike sneakers
to ever go dark they are serious and so
they are building
serious infrastructure these are
the chinese communist party will burn
the entire plant to the ground
before they they see power absolutely
well also if you remember they're the
ones taking a lot of the plastic from
the west
there's a big controversy between them
and canada recently as well
and a lot of people found out when they
were taking the plastic to allegedly
recycle it and were being paid to
recycle it what they were doing
they were throwing it in the water and
that's why we have this huge
island made of plastic that specifically
came from china and what are they doing
now they're not only polluting and
throwing a lot of waste on the water
they're also expanding their wetter
sorry part of me here their weather
modification program
which of course they actively used they
used during they used it
used it during their olympics but
they're now making sure that they're
going to be able to manipulate
the environment to their own personal
benefit which is going to hurt
a lot of countries surrounding them as
well we saw a lot of tragic stories
coming out of china specifically with
them trying to stop rain during the
olympics causing massive flooding in
other areas
they're now expanding this to huge
levels that we don't even
know about don't even comprehend and the
devastating effects from this will be
far bigger than even some pollution
according to some experts i think
there's just cultural differences though
between us you're right you're right
cultural norms cultural you know i
i have so much respect for joe biden he
didn't want to be a xenophobe like trump
was
you know how dare trump call out china
for not warning for
for lying to the world about the
coronavirus and igniting this massive
pandemic
and it wasn't bigoted of him because the
only reason he did it was because
it's china yeah that's the only reason
and china has so many vulnerabilities
that if we were serious about
freedom and and the livelihood of our
fellow mankind
we could [ __ ] china they need to
import 12 million barrels
a day of oil whoa you don't want to be
racist there buddy
you can't talk about china like that joe
biden says it's just cultural
differences you know we got to let them
do their thing
right we we could just stop sending all
of our jobs there right
we could stop buying nike sneakers we
could stop stop
watching disney right like we could
easily end the china wrath but we just
choose not to because it's convenient
it's cheap
this is why this is why i was saying
part of me just wants like
a legitimate call for people to get
back to nature to some degree go out and
tend to the chickens man
chickens are hilarious i don't
understand how a person could look at a
chicken and not laugh yeah
it's it's like watching them do their
thing is like it's just hilarious and
watch chickens do their thing
and maybe this pandemic has showed us
that you really
can live anywhere right if we can work
uh
remotely then then get the hell and i'm
from queens so anyone who's from queens
you know
get get the heck out of queens go just a
couple you know
it's 60 70 miles and your life will
change dramatically the air is better oh
the tree is nicer i had a hard time
leaving la
like i felt like i was failing like i
failed in my life
because i was leaving the mecca but it's
just the day of decentralization is upon
us
so we have out here a city
a city of cardinals i've never seen
so many cardinals when so it's it's
snowed recently
everything is white i look in the tree
and there's red spots all over the tree
and i was like
damn yeah living in the city you see one
and you go hey look a cardinal oh man
exactly out here it's like all the
cardinals won't go away yeah
yeah and you see bluebirds and you see
different flowers and you hear different
sounds
and if if people got away from these
cities
rolled up their sleeves did a little bit
of hard work their lives would improve
and it would cut off the supply line to
these corrupt companies
like disney praising the paramilitaries
in xinjiang
it would cut off nba and these other
companies it's like it's
i'm reminded of that simpsons episode
just don't look you know the trash of
horror when the advertisements come to
life just don't look
i i got to tell you man if i had a
choice between watching the super bowl
and watching a chicken walk around
i picked the chicken i'm not kidding
it's funny it's just like it's hilarious
because you look so dumb
i caught myself staring out the window
this morning if the snow falling
for like 10 minutes i was just standing
there beautiful
looking outside and it was like betsy
was sitting next to me the cat
and it was like she was watching outside
too and i realized it's like tv
like we're watching it's like better tv
in a lot of ways it is tv for cats
people are a lot happier and healthier
living out in the wild living out in
nature
there's no crazy crackheads there's no
pollution there's no stress
there's no guy beating you over the head
with a baseball bat which just
there's a viral video going around in
new york city right now there's no cuomo
putting sick people into your
into your nursing home and killing your
parents threatening assembly members
that they're gonna be destroyed if they
don't say nice things about
that particular response yeah i mean i
lived in the city too growing up
and uh i hate it i'm so happy i'm not
there anymore and i'm telling you like
you feel stuck
in there i mean i felt stuck i was like
i can't leave new york city if you can't
make it in new york city you can't make
it anywhere yeah i
i love the city i love the nightlife i
love being able to go out and then
covet happen and then i'm like this is
an absolute
police state tyrannical hell hole that's
the epitome
of the worst elements of communism mixed
in with big brother literally
stomping you in the face with its boot
every single chance and opportunity that
they get
there's new york city inspection
officers literally running around
with binoculars trying to look through
your windows to make sure that you're
not
it's socially distinguishing enough
there's people rummaging through your
trash even before covid making sure you
recycled correctly meanwhile the whole
recycling uh
whole agenda is a scam anyway thanks for
checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time